The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com. The
David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com. Remember
that the number one way to support our
program is very simple grab a membership to
join Pacman dot com up through Election Day.
You can take advantage of the coupon code
20/20 now, two zero two zero A.W. no space, all
lowercase. Well, numbers can't be lowercase,
but you understand. Grab a membership and you will
also get access to the daily members only bonus
show and join Pacman dot com. So Donald Trump left
Walter Reed Medical Center yesterday. There's a
real question about the disease progression. We
don't really know exactly what his health status
is, but we didn't need to wonder too much. When
Donald Trump arrived back at the White House
in a complete propaganda moment. Donald Trump
defiantly stood saluting and watching Marine One,
the helicopter leave after depositing him back at
the White House. Donald Trump removed his mask and
what I guess was supposed to be framed as some
kind of act of courage, despite it being a very,
very risky given that Donald Trump, by all
accounts, is still very contagious. And what was
interesting about that moment is that as Donald
Trump stood and watched Marine One leave, you
can tell that he is struggling to breathe. Trump
is gasping for air and using his neck and upper
chest muscles to actually breathe. Medical experts
who watch this video agree that that is indeed
what we are seeing here. Donald Trump. At another
moment, again, after removing his mask, of course,
wincing in pain as he tries to breathe.
This is a sign of serious coronavirus still
affecting Donald Trump. And bear in mind that
this is Trump struggling to breathe while on
corticosteroids like dexamethasone,
typically reserved for patients in an ICU
with Corona virus on a ventilator with Corona
virus or having such breathing issues that
they are expected or projected to need that
level of care soon. That's who typically gets
dexamethasone. Donald Trump getting it. We've got
no clear explanation from his doctor as to whether
this was indeed because Donald Trump is that sick
or because he's merely the president. And they're
throwing everything at him. But Donald Trump,
they're wincing in pain, struggling to breathe.
Author Mike Juillet on Twitter posted some text
messages he exchanged with a cardiologist friend
of his from a major hospital. And what we are
seeing is the same thing that doctors are seeing.
Trump visibly struggling to breathe. The doctor
actually says saw a brief clip of his breathing
and it looks pretty bad. Watching a longer
stretch now. Not good. Breathing the same doctor
later adding that if he does go back to Walter
Reed, his chance of survival becomes quite low.
He will not go unless he is in dire straits. He
is basically getting hospital level care in the
White House. Now, the doctor also says Trump
can't get ICU care at the White House. There
is speculation that something close to an ICU has
been set up at the White House medical unit in the
event that it becomes necessary for Donald Trump.
We just don't know because they lie all the time,
constantly about everything. What we can surmise
is Trump probably is partially feeling okay enough
to start demanding a ride around the block and to
start manic tweeting and to demand it to go back
to the White House. Partially. He's feeling like
he can do that because he is on steroids that can
cause euphoria, mania and delusions of grandeur.
That's one piece of it. The other side is that the
disease can have a progression where once you were
seven to 10 days in, there is a sort of second
wave. Donald Trump reportedly plans to be at the
debate next Thursday. Is that possible? Well,
we just won't know until we get at least
did this weekend, at which point many people
get much worse and deteriorate. We really
don't know. Trump's doctors are not being being
forthcoming. And are we? We are going to have to
wait and see what we need to get on the table now.
Is Joe Biden must be protected at all costs. Joe
Biden had three negative Corona virus tests since
being presumably exposed at the first debate
last Tuesday. And if indeed Donald Trump plans
to be at next Thursday's debate, Joe Biden has
already said he will consult with his doctors
and figure out what it is that they advise
him to do. I would not find it overboard to
request that Biden be 20, 30 feet away from Donald
Trump, bring plexiglass, do whatever he has to do.
Biden must be kept safe from Donald Trump,
who has effectively become a super spreader.